people ask me why do you risk death for  me this is life it should be on IMAX and  you know and IMAX 3d was always the  reason to make the movie I wanted to  confess on the edge of my seat for the  first time in the history of cinema  millions of people they're gonna be  actually on the wire with me I'm going  to hang a high wire between the two  towers and work on it this is extremely  dangerous it's time to step on the wire  I don't know if I'll be able to take my  first step  your heart will tell you what to do I do  think that and Feldman's super beautiful  and IMAX think you'll want to see it in  IMAX 3d because it'll just be much more  of an experience I was having a sweat on  my pants during the walk because I was  transported back in the most important  day of my life  max  you